I think there needs to be a citizen's
revolt against the corporate takeover of
politics and we have to get out of this
reality TV show that is just the endless
popularity contest of elections and it's
it's an incredible distraction and
Americans are in an endless election
campaign it never ends so the idea that
after the election then there'll be
policy there's no after the election
there's always another election and
other fundraising campaign and you know
it never ends it's a big business onto
itself it's entertainment and it's
politics deferral so you know before
before this can actually lead to
political change we need to change the
rules we need to get corporate money the
hell away from politics or at least a
huge separation it has two it's the most
pressing issue of our time it's the most
pressing issue of our time because it's
what needs to happen before anything
else can happen
you